وجهه غير معروف لعامه
الناساعد مدير الاداره الرئاسيه
الاوكرانيه قدم استقالته لا سبب رسمي معلن
لكن ورد اسمه في فضيحه استخدام السيارات
فارغه بحسب وسائل اعلام الاوكرانيه معه
استقال عدد من كبار المسؤولين من بينهم
نائب وزير الدفاع ونائب المدعي العام
الاستقالات جاءت بعد ساعات من الكشف عن
عمليات شراء امدادات للجيش باسعار مبالغ
بها
يعملون في مراكز مختلفه في الوزارات
وهياكل الحكومه المركزيه وفي المناطق وفي
انظمه تطبيق القانون
الف دولار لتسهيل ابرام عقود شراء معدات
لذات باسعار مبالغ فيها كل ذلك بينما
تواجه اوكرانيا نقصا في الكهرباء بعد
الضربات الروسيه على منشات الطاقه وفقا
لمنظمه الشفافيه الدوليه غير الحكوميه
كانت اوكرانيا تحتل المركز 122 في قائمه
الدول الاكثر فسادا في العالم قبل الحرب
يويو الماضي دعاه رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه كييف الى تكفيف حربها ضد الفساد
فعل المحك مليارات من المساعدات الدوليه
الممنوحه لاوكرانيا لاعاده الاعمار